welcome to my PyCon 2020 talk entitled
beautiful Python refactoring my name is
Connor Hoekstra and I go by code
underscore reports on Twitter and
YouTube a little bit about me before we
hop into the talk I'm a senior library
software engineer working for nvidia on
the rapids AI team our team is
developing a end end data science
pipeline that runs on the GPU so if
you're interested in checking that out
check us out at rapid AI
I am a programming language enthusiast
so my majority of my experience is in
C++ and Python but I'm actively learning
several other languages at all times the
team that I work on primarily uses C++
14 and Python 3 I love algorithms and
beautiful code I have a youtube channel
at youtube.com slash code report where I
solve competitive programming problems
in a variety of different languages so
if you're interested check that out and
as I mentioned before I my alias online
is code underscore report so if you're
trying to search me sometimes that's
easier than searching my name so why am
I giving this talk approximately half a
year ago or maybe later depending on
when you're watching this talk online I
joined the Nvidia rapids team
specifically I work on the ku DF library
so there are multiple libraries that
exist within the rapids organization or
that the rapid organization is working
on and I work on the KU TF library so
the COO in each of these libraries comes
from CUDA which is the parallel
programming platform and programming
model or at least that's what the online
website says I like to think of CUDA as
the programming language that you can
use to do GPU computing and the DF and
qu D F stands for data frame so there
are typically two data frames that I
know of obviously the ku DF library
because that's the one that I work on or
the team that I work on develops and the
other more widely known data frame
library is
so if you're not familiar with pandas
the one-line description from their
website is pandas is a fast powerful
flexible and easy to use open-source
data analysis and manipulation tool
built on top of the Python programming
language and the one-line description of
Kuh DF is that ku DF provides a pandas
like API that will be familiar to data
engineers and data scientists so they
can use it to easily accelerate their
workflows without going into the details
of CUDA programming so the data frame
python api is modeled very closely on
the pandas api so that data scientists
that are familiar with working with
pandas will find it very easy to
transition to the kudiye for rapid data
frame library if they need to accelerate
the data science that they are doing so
when I started back in October I thought
that it would be good to familiarize
myself with the pandas library so I
decided that I was going to work on a
small toy project that could use pandas
to manipulate some data or analyze some
data so that I could get familiar with
pandas so I decided that what I was
going to do was analyse the data that is
on one of the competitive programming
websites that I occasionally compete on
and cover on my youtube channel that is
code forces and they give you data on
the number of submissions whether
they're successful or they fail and what
I was most curious about which was the
language that you are submitting it in
so the question that I came up with was
what are the most popular programming
languages used on sites like code forces
so for this talk I'm basically going to
show the steps that I went through to
get that code working and throughout
that process I ended up refactoring a
lot of code that I had pulled off of a
website and in from a blog in particular
and I think it is going to be really
illustrative and hopefully you'll find
it educational and be able to learn from
a few of the refactorings that I did and
improve the quality of the code that
you're writing on a day to day basis so
how do we go about doing this it's
really only two steps the first step is
to scrape the HTML date
from the code forces website with pandas
and the second step is to analyze that
data with pandas and once we're done
those steps we're done so for the
duration of this talk 90% of it will
take place in step number one because
that is where all of the refactorings
that I did occurred but I also spend the
last 10% of the talk showing you the
analysis with pandas just to motivate
why you might be interested in picking
up pandas or a library like ku DF so how
do we go about scraping HTML with pandas
I had no idea so what does any engineer
do when they have no idea they go to
Google and they type in what they'd like
to do scrape HTML with pandas I did this
and in the second results I found web
scraping HTML tables with Python that
had a reference to the pandas dataframe
in it so I open that up and I got to the
following blog and this blog takes you
step-by-step through how to set up a
piece of code that will basically scrape
the information that you want from an
HTML table so I went through this and at
the end of it it's about 60 plus lines
of code depending on how you look at it
and we're gonna quickly go through and
sort of highlight each of the sections
of that code that they sort of break
apart in the blog so the first section
is the imports which is pretty
straightforward nothing really we need
to talk about here requests is for
getting the HTML LX ml is for being able
to parse and read the HTML and then
pandas is for the data frame that we're
going to set up at the end the second
section is initializing the page doc and
T are elements that we're going to use
to do the scraping after that we have
our first for loop which is used to
extract the titles from each of the
columns in our table that is on the code
Forces website the second piece of code
that involves for loops is two nested
for-loops which is used for basically
extracting the contents of our HTML HTML
table in each of the columns of the
table and then at the very end we
construct a data frame from a dictionary
that is constructed using a dick
comprehension so the first piece of code
that we are going to look at is going to
be the first for loop that we showed you
so here we have initialization of an
empty list Co L and an index I and then
we have a for loop that goes through
each one reads something from each
element of our TR elements data
structure and then it pens it at the
very end so we're gonna remove the
comments here one primarily just to make
the text bigger but two because these
comments are a little bit redundant we
don't really need a comment to tell us
that we are constructing or initializing
an empty list here so we remove the
comments and the first thing that we
notice about this code is the following
pattern we are initializing an index I
then looping through each of the
elements in our TR elements first row
and then right after that we're doing an
increment to our index if you ever have
this pattern where you're initializing
an index outside a loop and then inside
your loop incrementing it there is a
function or an algorithm for this in
Python called enumerate so using
enumerate we can basically remove the
initialization of our index and the
incrementing of our index and pass our
TR elements first row to enumerate and
then using D structuring we can D
structure the now zipped indexed with
each of our elements in TR elements into
int so I will be our index and T will be
the elements that we were originally
getting from our TR elements first row
so this is an algorithm that's known by
a couple different names in different
languages if you found yourself at this
video is a not a Python programmer so
it's primarily known as enumerates in
languages like Python rust and B but in
other languages it's also known as with
index in Ruby Cullen and elixir and also
as indexed in racket in Haskell so this
is a very very useful algorithm I've
seen this pattern many times where
people are initializing an index outside
a range base for
that doesn't give you the index and then
they're incrementing it inside the
for-loop
if you can if your language has it and
python does try to make use of this
enumerate so the second thing that I
noticed was that the index that we are
now getting from enumerate is actually
only used in one place and that's in
this print statement I'm not exactly
sure what the initial purpose of this
print statement was probably for
debugging purposes it's supposed to be
sort of a teaching blog so my guess is
this was to make it easier to understand
for the individual putting this code
together but at the end of the day you
don't actually need this print statement
so the second refactoring that we can do
is just to delete the print and then the
enumerate that we just added and that
will look as follows and at this point
we can start to see that we can actually
probably change this for loop into a
list comprehension so if we get rid of
the name variable and put the T dot text
content directly inside the append call
you can see that this is really doable
in a list comprehension which is going
to be our third change so list
comprehensions give you the ability to
basically construct a list in place
without having to violate what I call
the ITM anti-pattern which is my least
favorite anti-pattern that i see all the
time in code so once again I TM this is
an anti-pattern that you should try to
avoid at all costs and it is my assert a
ssin that if you can avoid this
anti-pattern your code will become more
readable more made more maintainable and
just better in general so I TM it stands
for initialized then modify we've seen
it twice already the first example was
when we had the code that could be
replaced by a call to enumerate here
we're initializing the index I and then
inside the form loop immediately
modifying it we can avoid this by using
enumerate and in my opinion it makes the
code easier to read the second example
where we saw this was in the code that
we just saw where we're initializing
column and then immediately inside our
for loop
calling the append method on that list
for every iteration of our for loop we
can avoid this as I just said with a
list comprehension so if you can try to
avoid the ITM anti-pattern it leads like
I said to in general better and more
readable code so moving on to our second
set of four loops that we're going to
look at and refactor this is the code
that is responsible for basically
extracting the data from the columns of
each of our tables so we're gonna look
at this nested for loop bit by bit
and the first bit we're gonna look at is
this if statement sort of on the third
and fourth line so here it says that if
the row size is not of size ten that
means that it's not from our table when
I ran this on the pokemons dataset that
originally came with this blog I didn't
run into this and I'm definitely not
going to have this issue with the code
forces data so we're able to just delete
this if statement this won't always be
the case when you're refactoring but for
your use case if you find that this is
the case you can definitely just remove
redundant code that's not doing anything
the second change that we're gonna make
to these nested for-loops is by taking a
look at the first two lines of our first
for loop so here we have for J in range
1 to the length of our TR elements list
and we're then using that J which is
going to be an index to assign T to be
the J element of our TR elements so this
was a bit confusing to me when I first
looked at it because I thought why
aren't you just looping over the
second-to-last elements of TR elements
but I figured that would be because we
actually need TR elements again however
when I looked at where T out TR elements
gets used it's only in the first two
lines so it became obvious that we're
able to use something called slicing
here in order to avoid having to use the
range function calculate an index and
then indexing into TR elements to set T
we can just use slicing to immediately
at tea in our for loop so that looks as
follows we use slicing to basically drop
the first element of our tea our
elements list and this is going to give
us the second to last elements in our
list tea our elements so this is exactly
what we want and we are able to avoid
not only a second line of code but also
a call to the function range which is
fantastic the next thing we're going to
look at is a pattern that we've seen
before hopefully you were able to
identify it we're setting an index I
inside of and then inside of for loop
incrementing this index for each
iteration of the for loop hopefully you
remember what we did earlier and that is
making use of the enumerate function I
said it before but I see this pattern
all the time and when you're in a
language like Python that has this
algorithm or function it is a godsend in
certain languages like go they actually
have it built into their range based for
loops which is a really really
interesting design choice for the
language but yes use this one you can it
makes your code much more readable like
I said and it avoids the ITM
anti-pattern the next change that we're
gonna make is taking a look at another
if statement once again this if
statement says check if the row is empty
I ran this on the Pokemon data set
didn't run into any of these cases and
also it's not going to be an issue for
my code forces data so this can be
removed as we the same as we remove the
previous if statement
the next piece of code that we're gonna
look at are the four lines in the middle
that are the try and accept and if we
read the comment above these four lines
of code it says convert any numerical
value to an integer I don't think that
this is the best way that we could be
doing this I try to avoid try and accept
statements when possible so the way that
we can improve this piece of code is to
use something called a conditional
expression in many other languages you
can get the same effect by using
something called a ternary operator
which is typically the question mark
combined with the colon but in Python it
looks as follows it basically enables
you to assign the assignment based on a
conditional statement but it combines it
with sort of an if and an else so it
becomes an expression so the way that it
reads is basically value one if
conditional else value two so if the
conditional is true it uses value on
otherwise it uses value two so here to
set the data
we're basically casting our data to an
integer if the data is numeric otherwise
just using the piece of data so I like
this better than the previous code
because one it's a single line but two
it avoids the try and accept which I
think you should try to avoid if
possible and once again I just really
like avoiding the ITM anti-pattern
technically we are modifying the data
here but in the next couple of changes
we're going to avoid that as well so the
next change is to remove the redundant
comments so if we read the two comments
here the first one is to iterate through
each element of the row I think any
comment above a for loop that is just
saying we're iterating through each
element of insert what we're iterating
through this isn't really adding any
value as a comment similar to the second
comment append the data to the empty
list of the ice column this is pretty
self-explanatory
by just reading the fact that we have a
two-dimensional list and we are
appending to the ithe column so we can
remove both of these and also like I
said remove the second assignment to
data and just put that code in the
append method that we are invoking
and at this point we are going to stop
and just see how far we've come so if we
go back to what we originally started
with we had roughly 60-plus lines of
code and at this point we're down to
about 20 so we've eliminated 2/3 of our
code if we reformat the comments on the
first four lines we can even get this a
little bit more compact which I prefer
and at this point we have all of our
code on a single slide which makes it a
little bit easier or a lot easier to
reason about holistically and we can
start to notice something about the code
structurally and that is that we are
initializing our list of tuples col2
initially have the title of our column
as the first element of each of the
tuples in our list and the second
element is just initially empty and then
in our nested for-loops below we filled
the contents of these empty lists with
the contents of each of the
corresponding columns which we can see
with this you know call bracket I
bracket bracket 1 bracket however if we
look at what we do with this list of
tuples immediately after in this
dictionary comprehension we immediately
D structure it which begs the question
why are we bundling these together in a
list of tuples why can't we just have
two separate lists because it's a little
bit awkward to have to index into our
column to then append to sort of an
empty list when we could just have a
list of Lists for the column data and a
single list for the column titles so
that's exactly what we're going to do so
the first step is to basically get rid
of the tuple in our list call and rename
this to be titles and then once we've
done that we've broken this code down
here so we need to add a second what
will be a list of Lists and so we can
construct this list and we'll call it
CLS for columns
initialize it to be the number of
columns that we need and now instead of
having to do
to indexing into this data structure we
can just do a single one and the next
change we can make is to sort of factor
out this transformation that we're
performing on the data that is T dot
text content so we can factor this out
into a lambda and at this point we can
pretty clearly see that we can transform
this nested for loop into a list
comprehension because we have the
pattern once again we're initializing
our list outside here and then inside
that we are calling append for every
iteration of our nested for-loops
which whenever you see this you should
think list comprehension so the
equivalent list comprehension is as
follows if you're not used to lip list
comprehension syntax this might be a
little bit confusing but once you get
used to it it's no more difficult to
read than the nested for-loops were
originally so we're basically
constructing a list for each T in TR
from the second element to the last
element and we are calling the format
function on each of the T dot text
contents for the T's in the Teeter
children and note that we're also making
a call which is a bit tricky to this
function called zip and then we're also
using an asterisk at the beginning this
is the equivalent of a transpose in many
other languages so if we take a look at
our huugle translate sort of function or
algorithm comparison you can see that in
almost every single language and library
this is called transposed only in a
couple do they call it something
slightly different
so yes unfortunate in Python that they
don't have an explicitly named transform
transpose function but you can get the
same behavior by just calling zip
parentheses asterisks and then your
two-dimensional collection and then end
parenthesis so at this point we're done
we've reduced our code from 60 plus
lines down to depending on how you look
on it you know roughly ten lines which
is great the question is are we done can
we do better and some of you might have
noticed that I have made a really really
big mistake
and that mistake is that I didn't paying
close enough attention when I was
googling some of you might have been
thinking even I didn't do any of my HDL
HTML scraping with pandas I didn't use
pandas until I was constructing the data
frame from the dictionary comprehension
at the very end and if I had been paying
more close attention I would have seen
that right below this result there was a
panda's dot read HTML method and if we
make use of this method it turns these
roughly ten lines of code
five or three lines of code depending on
how you look at it so this is extremely
important if you've seen any of my other
talks about algorithms I echo the point
that has been made by several other
individuals in other programming
communities that you should know your
algorithms but not only should you know
your algorithms you should know your
collections and you should know your
libraries too I think all of the work
that I did refactoring the code that I
worked on it was useful it was a useful
learning exercise and it's hopefully
going to be useful some of the things
that I mentioned in this talk but I
could have avoided all of that if I had
just known the pandas API better and I
was just starting out with it so I
didn't know so you know it's okay that
we make these mistakes but over time we
should try to use our libraries and our
collections and our algorithms as much
as possible to avoid writing all this
unnecessary code whether it be ten lines
of code or sixty lines of code ideally
if there's a library with a single
method that does exactly what you want
that's what you should be using so if
you want to go check out all of the step
by step changes there were nine of them
that I explicitly mentioned and then two
of them at the end that I implicitly
mentioned you can check out the link at
the end of this talk on my github page I
have a file that has a git commit
history with all of the explicit changes
if you want to see them sort of in the
github file diff mode so we finished
step one onto step two this one's a lot
shorter than the first step as I said
this is only going to be about 10% of
the talk and so first we need to look at
what does the HTML table that I've been
referring to this whole time look like
so on the code force's website for each
contest you can go to the status of each
of the submissions and it will show you
all of the languages whether they passed
or failed and for which problem in the
contest they were submitted for and so
primarily we're interested in the column
title laying short for language but one
thing you'll notice is that they don't
just have a single submission option if
you are submitting in C++ you can choose
several different compilers C++ 11 17 14
for Python they have
the option to submit Python 3 or python
2 there are various different sort of
mappings from inputs or submission
method compared to language so the first
thing we need to do is create a
dictionary that map's all of the
different submission options to the
language that is being submitted in once
we do that we have a very short piece of
code for lines we're importing pandas
were initializing and declaring our
dictionary mapping once we've executed
the code that we created in step one and
stored it to a CSV we can just load this
as such I was doing this for code forces
educational code contest 74 and then
once we have our data frame we can
access a single column in that data
frame by going dot Lang and then we can
call the algorithm or method replace
which is basically going to do that
transformation of mapping each of these
submission methods to the corresponding
language and then we make a final call
to value counts so if you're familiar
with the collection counter in Python
value counts is very similar it
basically is going to give you a
frequency count of the unique elements
that exists in a series or a list so in
pandas and the rapids Python API this is
called value counts in the two Lisp
dialects closure and racket this is
called frequency and as mentioned before
in Python it's not an algorithm but it's
a collection but it has a very similar
behavior this is called counter and so
once we do this we get the following
output so you can see there are 41
thousand submissions in C++ two and a
half thousand in Python just under two
thousand and Java and if we visualize
this it looks as follows so
overwhelmingly the language of choice at
least for this contest but it's
typically the case for most contest was
C++ with 89 percent of the submissions
if we get rid of C++ we can see that the
next top three our Python with six
percent Java with four percent and C
with one percent and for what I will
call the fringe languages any language
that had less than one percent of the
submissions the rankings are as follows
C sharp Pascal
hotland javascript rust go purl d
haskell PHP and Ruby and second to last
thing I want to mention is that if you
are looking to accelerate your data
science work that you are working on and
you have a bottleneck when it comes to
performance a lot of the times when
you're using pandas you can simply drop
in replace cootie F which is the library
that the in videos rapid team works on
and your code will work so this work
this code works exactly the same as it
did in pandas it works in cootie F and
it's just gonna be a lot more
performance if you're working with a lot
of data and you have the GPUs to run
this on so if you're if you're sort of
wondering well you know pandas works for
me that's great keep using pandas but if
if you do have a performance bottleneck
cootie F can be a great alternative and
coincidentally while I was on my run
today I typically like to listen to
podcasts these are the five that I was
listening to and one of them that I
listened to just happened to be an
interview with an individual by the name
of Kyle Nicholson who works at Capital
One and apparently they're using Rapids
and he mentioned in the podcast that for
the sort of code that they were working
with the code base or the the training
model that they were working with they
had a roughly 30x reduction in cost and
a roughly a hundred x speed-up in the
time to train their model so it's
extremely impressive the things that you
can do with this rapid could EF library
if performance is a bottleneck for you
and if you're interested check this out
at rapid day I and the last thing that I
want to mention randomly is a blog that
was mentioned on a podcast called Python
bites this blog was entitled eight
coolest Python programming language
features the reason I mentioning it is
that five of the eight features either
directly or indirectly were referenced
in this talk which I thought was kind of
coincidental so the first one was list
comprehensions which we used multiple
times to refactor for loops generator
expressions weren't directly mentioned
but their go hand-in-hand with list
comprehensions slice assignment we
didn't use but we did use slicing to
move that one assignment to tea and the
call to the range function iterable
iterable unpacking this is what I refer
to as D structuring where you are taking
a tuple or a list and D structuring it
into its individual components and then
dictionary comprehensions was being used
at the end to construct our dictionary
that we were passing to create a data
frame so a great article I definitely
recommend you checking it out and yeah
hopefully you found this useful thanks
for watching I know it's a bit odd
without having an audience and me just
recording this by myself and
unfortunately there is an opportunity to
ask live questions they which is why
there is an asterisks next to this but
if you do have questions leave them in
the comment section down below or if you
want you can tweet them at me at code
underscore report I will do my best to
monitor the YouTube comments section and
to reply to any questions you have and
last but not least all of the slides and
the code that I've shown in this talk
are posted on my github page so if
you're interested check them out there